it's now been two weeks since russia
started this onslaught against the
people of ukraine and after 14 days
we're waking up to additional threats
emerging from this war zone
it's a stark reality but what happens in
ukraine could destroy more than just
europe
last week
we reported on russia's attack and
eventual occupation of europe's largest
nuclear power plant
after a fire broke out following an
assault by russian forces alarm bells
went off across the world
that we could be witnessing a nuclear
meltdown
luckily that didn't happen
as the facility held up without leaking
radiation
and we dodged a bullet
but russia's stupidity knows no bounds
they were willing to attack a nuclear
plant
so what else are they willing to destroy
well we know russia's one big fake news
operation brainwashing its own people
into thinking they're the good guys in
this war
so it's safe to assume their troops are
falling for similar propaganda and
they're a largely conscripted army made
up of you know young misinformed kids
you mix young stupid troops with guns
and a nuclear reactor and you could see
why the world held its breath for a
moment last week
and unfortunately
this isn't the only unforeseen risk
emerging from ukraine yesterday
on capitol hill under secretary of state
victoria nuland went before the senate
where she had this exchange with senator
marco rubio listen
does ukraine have chemical or biological
weapons
ukraine has a
biological research facilities
which in fact we are now quite concerned
russian troops russian forces
may be seeking to
gain control of so we are working with
the ukrainians on how they can
prevent any of those
research materials from falling into the
hands of
russian forces should they approach
bio labs in ukraine
bio labs you heard that right
there's been a lot of talk you know
propaganda and fake news regarding this
whole thing so we wanted to look into it
this afternoon
the first question we had was
why are these labs in ukraine
and what role is the united states
played in making that possible
well part of it comes from an expansion
of the none luger cooperative threat
reduction program way back in 2005.
this agreement was put into place quote
improves security for pathogens
stored at biological research and health
facilities in the former soviet republic
under the agreement ctr funds will for
the first time flow directly to projects
aimed at securing pathogen strains
and sensitive biological knowledge
within ukraine
the plan
came together through the work of two
u.s senators dick lugar
one of the namesakes of the program and
a junior senator from illinois named
barack obama
you may remember this dick i was in
ukraine we went to a facility an old
factory
we walked down these long dark corridors
we're ducking our heads stepping over
puddles of something we're not sure what
it was
so we know these facilities exist and
how they got there but
what are they actually doing inside
well
according to a national review report
citing a 2011 conference organized by
the u.s state department's
biosecurity engagement program
the facility is described as a bio
safety level 3 lab
which works
with microbes that can cause serious or
deadly diseases through inhalation eg
like covid19 tuberculosis yellow fever
sars
west nile
some strains of influenza
so these labs are a petri dish
of some of the world's most contagious
diseases
and they're sitting in a war zone
you can see why we're a little concerned
and from what we can understand
ukraine's level three labs
are found in odessa and kiev
guess which two cities russian troops
are closing in on
odessa and keith
these two facilities could very well be
in putin's hands in a matter of days
and then what happens
well newland
said she was quite concerned about
russia getting hold of the research
and it's not surprising why because just
because something was not created as a
weapon
does it mean
it can't be used as a weapon
we only have to look back two years to
see what happened in wuhan
or gain a function research led to a
pandemic that killed millions
across the globe millions
and why did
we work to put these facilities in
ukraine
putin hasn't been shy about his desire
to invade the country for years
couldn't our leaders have found a more
friendly place for their research
we know the russians are stupid enough
to attack one of the largest nuclear
plants in europe
do we really trust them to handle highly
contagious viruses
with the proper precaution
it's unbelievable hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else